all right we didn't get to this last
week because we had such a busy week but
I do want to point out that I have had
my record-setting most popular Instagram
picture in history Pat posted over the
last 10 days of course i'm on instagram
at david pakman i am now involved in
well which picture do we want to put up
first I'll talk through a couple
pictures yes so the two things that do
really really well on Instagram are
number one when I hold a baby naturally
and that seems to do well for
politicians it seems to really there's a
reason why politicians regularly pickup
babies I posted a picture of me holding
my friend's youngest daughter and my
instagram account exploded imploded call
it what you will and people commenting
the baby looks scared the baby looks
happy it's so amazing that you're now a
father David which of course this isn't
my kid this is my friend kid and
something about pictures with babies it
really does it for for the men and the
women I will say I'm just surprised that
you were trusted with such a
responsibility you know I can hold
babies I've got a younger sister that
was a baby when I went when I was a you
know a late teenager and I was acting a
one-handed approach to I was proficient
in in holding her so okay you can see me
holding a baby not my baby if you go if
you find David Pakman on Instagram and
then I am also embroiled in an urban
gardening project I now have initially
planted six different types of herbs on
my balcony here in Boston oh I just like
the idea of hey listen I'm going to cook
something I'm going to go out there and
I'll cut some basil and I've got the
basil and then in a few weeks it grows
again and it's all fantastic I got six
plants okay I started with parsley basil
rosemary cilantro chives and cilantro
chives and what was the other one and
dill okay of course
three per planter for some reason it
rained one of the planters something
about maybe the gutter system on my
balcony poured about six gallons of
water into one of my planters instantly
flooding and killing half of my plan so
basically what I have left at this point
is parsley basil and rosemary and the
other day I went out there
and I was cooking up some eggplant parm
and what better than fresh basil for
your eggplant parm and I took I put up
this picture of me cutting the basil and
people liked this picture something
about this picture people really seemed
into yeah I mean the herbs grow fast
enough that I think in a few weeks you
can try this again
right even though the initial ones
flooded you'll have a second chance I
think I absolutely will and I encourage
you to follow my urban gardening
experience on instagram at david pakman